انفجرت هذه الطائره في السماء فتسببت
باكبر كارثه على الارض انكر الامريكيون
اثارها المدمره لكن الاسبان عانى ولا
يزالون يعانون من تاثيرها حتى اليوم قصه
كارثه القنابل الهيدروجينيه التي احدثت
فوضى نوويه على السواحل الاسبانيه قبل نحو
60 عاما القنبله الهيدروجينيه سلاح نووي
مرعب الطاقه المدمره لقنبله منها تزن 80
طنا تعادل انفجار 20 مليون طن من ماده تي
ان تي عند نقل هذه القنابل جوا لابد من
الالتزام باعلى معايير الحيطه والحذر فاي
خطا بسيط قد يؤدي الى كارثه وهو ما وقع
بالفعل في السابع عشر من يناير من عام
في هذا التاريخ اقلعت الطائره ب 52 جي من
قاعده الجويه بحامله اربع قنابل
هيدروجينيه اتجهت الطائره شرقا عبر المحيط
الاطلسي والبحر الابيض المتوسط وتطلبت
الرحله الطويله تزويد الطائره بالوقود في
الجو فوق اسبانيا فاقلعت باتجاهها طائره
التزود بالوقود
135 من قاعده مرونه الجويه في الجنوب
الاسباني ليقع ما لم يكن في الحسب انفجر
خزان طائره التزود بالوقود فقتل سبعه من
طاقم الطائرتين البالغ عددهم 11 فرضا
هناك اجراء لدى قائد طائرات الوقود بحيث
اذا شعر مشغل ذراع الرافعه انك تقترب
كثيرا وان الموقف خطير على الفور يتصل بنا
ليخبرنا بكلمات انفصل انفصل انفصل ومع عدم
دعوتنا من قائد طائره الوقود للانفصال لم
نشعر اننا في خطر لكن فجاه بدا ان كل
الجحيم ينفجر
احترقت الطائرتان وسقطت ثلاث قنابل
هيدروجينيه على قريه بالموريس في الميريا
الاسبانيه
والرابعه استقرت في قاع البحر ورغم ان
القنابل لم تنفجر الا ان اثنين من اجهزه
التفجير المملوءه بالبلوتونيوم اطلاق ما
يزيد عن ثلاثه كيلو جرامات من البلوتونيوم
239 المشع على الفور ارسلت الولايات
المتحده نحو 1600 جندي الى موقع التحطم
لاستعاده الاسلحه وتنظيف التلوث لكن دراسه
اجريت في عام 2007 اظهرت ان مساحه قد تصل
ل 50 الف متر مربع لا تزال ملوثه ما ادى
الى تطويق المنطقه المتضرره بسياج ومنع
استخدامها للزراعه او التنميه
اسبانيا طلبت رسميا من الولايات المتحده
اتخاذ اجراء لازاله التربه المشعه استنادا
اتفاقيه غير ملزمه ابرمها البلدان عام
وتضمنت تعهد الامريكيا بنقل اجزاء التربه
الملوثه لموقع المناسب في الولايات
المتحده
الى يومنا هذا تطالب السلطات في اسبانيا
الولايات المتحده بارسال قواتها لاخذ ما
تبقى من ارثه النووي المشع الذي تغلغل في
اراضي تلك المنطقه لكن واشنطن لا تزال
تهون من شان الكارثه حتى انها لم ترد على
اي طلب رسمي بشان معدلات الاشعاع بمكان
الحادثه واثباتا لذلك
ظهر السفير الامريكي في اسبانيا ويدعى
السيد بدلت اوك في فتره وقوع الكارثه
ليقوم بغطسه دبلوماسيه في البحر الابيض
المتوسط بالقرب من موقع التحطم لاظهار عدم
وجود خطر نشاط اشعاعي هناك ناتج عن
القنبله الهيدروجينيه المفقوده